c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui ne
voulait pas que sa toute petite fille
l'oubli georges steven conflit est un
lieutenant colonel de l'armée canadienne
qui a combattu en france lors de la
première guerre mondiale
ce montréalais d'origine et père de cinq
enfants
sa petite dernière célia nakane ans
lorsqu'il part se battre pour elle il va
cueillir ses fleurs sur les champs de
bataille et dans les prêts qu'ils
traversent
il les fait sécher dans un livre avant
de les envoyer
même en temps de guerre dans la dans la
noirceur il était capable de penser à
l'amour à sa famille et d'avoir un petit
peu d'espoir de marché dans les champs
comme il était en train de faire dans le
temps est gris puis prendre un flat
pouces a fait la botaniste archiviste
qui a conçu le montage des lettres et
des fleurs a été bouleversée et
émerveillée par ce travail délicat et
jamais je n'ai éprouvé autant d'émotions
en manipulant des spécimens il ya
quelque chose de très intime dans la
relation d'un père qui envoie une fleur
à sa petite fille et malgré qu'on soit
scientifique
on en rêve imprégné on reste imprégnée
de cette émotion que nous sommes flamme
peut transmettre à travers les années
selon le concept victorien de la flore
you graphie les fleurs sont associés à
des émotions la rose jaune à l'amour
filial labruyère à la solitude la
pâquerette à l'amour maternel et cetera
l'exposition identifie ainsi 10 fleurs
cueillies par le soldat quand tu lis
illustré dans des stations où on rend
également hommage des canadiens ayant
participé à ce conflit
les artefacts présenter viennent de
france et de belgique
toutes les archives sont canadiennes et
on appuie et le visiteur peut aussi
stimuler son odorat
car une paire fumeuse a conçu des
senteurs pour illustrer les émotions
et aux fleurs dans chacune des stations
on découvre 10 parfum qui évoque le la
symbolique des fleurs mais aussi qui
rend hommage à des portraits donc des
femmes et des hommes
l'exposition rend aussi hommage à toutes
les victimes canadiennes de ce terrible
conflit
c'est la première fois dans une
exposition qu'on allait 68000 nom de
toutes les canadiens qui sont décédés
dans la première guerre mondiale
une exposition originale et innovante
qui nous fait réaliser que cette guerre
centenaire a encore bien des échos dans
notre monde d'aujourd'hui
ici catherine françois radio canada
montréal